so uh the story is tobias elwood he's a
senior uh tory mp as you said he's
actually the chairman of the defense
committee uh he's been a very very
outspoken uh unashamed as it were a
critic of boris johnson and boris
johnson's government so this isn't
necessarily the you know the biggest
surprise in the world that he did not
come back from his trip abroad to vote
in that confidence vote yesterday and
we've got this statement from the whips
office which says tobias always mp has
lost the conservative party whip
following his failure to vote in support
of the government in the confidence vote
last night that it's important to say it
was a vote in confidence that the
government not embarrassed johnson and
therefore
other tory mps voted uh that they had
confidence in the government essentially
in the meantime until we have a new uh
prime minister replacing boris johnson
in september now this is really serious
stuff uh it might be seen as potential
punishment or a potential kind of
penalty for tobias ellwood's uh lack of
loyalty to boris johnson lack of loyalty
to the government he's been so outspoken
about all of the scandals and all of the
problems uh under boris johnson's
premiership
so it's not necessarily the most um
surprising thing in the world but
considering he is such a a senior mp to
have the withdrawn like this it also
means he can now not vote in today's
leadership ballot which obviously every
vote counts when it comes to these
candidates and their campaigns so
whoever was potentially banking on
tobias elwood's vote is going to be
disappointed that that's one less vote
and
depending on how it gets after today and
how tight it goes that could be a very
valuable vote so potentially
disappointment for some people there now
we don't know what this means long term
depending on who becomes a prime
minister in september perhaps tobias may
get the whip reinstated it all depends
on who's the next prime minister as well
but uh obviously we know debra salwood
was abroad for that vote and was told to
come back to vote and he did not come
back and this is exactly why the whip
has been removed